so I want to talk to you about
here lies love which is this project
you've been working on for quite a while
I mean and and now it's going to get its
premiere on Broadway finally on July
20th this is what fascinates me is
the inspiration for this or the starting
point was your interest in Imelda Marcos
exactly now tell us how because that
that is not
again I have learned to expect the
unexpected
from David Byrne but when I say like
it's a it's going to be a musical and it
revolves around Imelda Marcos I think
that that is not you're I can't say
after that oh that old idea again
another musical about Imelda Marcos
please
ah yes all those songs about shoes
so where did this come from how did this
germinate uh
it goes back before that uh
not very often but a few times I went to
discos when there was a live act playing
and a live act playing in a disco meant
they would come in with a little tape
with their backing tracks with their
music on the tape put it in so it's like
a karaoke thing it'd be like Grace Jones
or Gloria Gaynor or Freda Payne or
different people who had hits in in
those days
they would stand on a little platform
the tape would play and they'd dance
around and sing live but the music was
pre-recorded and I thought oh that's
that's pretty nice it's a really short
set it's like 15 minutes because I don't
only have maybe two hits
um and then I'd heard the DJs the
in those kind of places saying there's
an arc to the evening there's where we
take the audience on a journey uh
dancing and maybe they're doing other
things but it's a it's an arc and I
thought but what if the ark was a story
what if you could tell a story using
those songs that they're singing
I just filed that away and then when I
read that Imelda Marcos that uh former
first lady of the Philippines loved
going to discos she had a mirror ball
installed in her New York townhouse she
turned the roof of the palace in Manila
into like a dance club I thought oh
here's a kind of
somewhat eccentric real life person who
has created that who lives in that world
yeah maybe this is the person whose
story could be told told that way so I
started doing research so what did you
find out about uh I mean for the longest
time she was held up as this
um if you don't know much about people
you just know the caricature about them
but as you did you become more
sympathetic at all to Imelda Marcos the
more you learned about her or no oh yeah
I think uh anybody who's writing about
uh another person or some situation like
that
you have to try and have empathize and
understand what drove them to do what
they did
uh if you don't if you just say oh she's
a bad bad bad bad person then story's
over right there right
so you have to try and understand it for
her yes there was a story she started
all it was a little bit of her extra
riches story
um poor girl from
the Poor Side of a very
influential family so she watched her
relatives
her richer relatives and she would have
to serve them tea and
things like that and she thought why are
they why them why them why not me
and so she became kind of ambitious and
kind of clawed away
up there she was very beautiful won some
beauty contests married a young Senator
got it got in there and yeah
lots and lots of things happened after
that to make to long story short uh
she did go to a lot of discos and
in the end
she and her husband her husband declared
martial law they put the country under
martial law which meant the Press is
muzzled any dissonance can just be
rounded up bad things happened
uh and eventually the populace
revolted but in a very peaceful way they
held an election but it was kind of a
fake election and like someone else we
know they claimed they won when they
hadn't right and
people just turned out on the streets
everywhere and just said no no no no
enough enough we're not having this
um and that might have been the end of
it uh they might have just said
who were you to say
the generals started defecting and
the cart and the Cardinal in the
Philippines whose name is cardinal sin
he defected that's almost you can't
write that stuff I thought what I'm
cardinal sin yeah
I thought oh no I can't say that people
will think oh you made that up
right uh yeah so then eventually yeah
after four days nobody got hurt uh they
gave up in the U.S Marines came in and
airlifted them out
so it has a happy ending but
the Marines came in there without his
happy ending well yeah well happy ending
for the people there uh however
now there's other stories the Marines
had lifted her out and stopped uh they
said we're going to you can be go to
Hawaii and which they did but she said
we need to stop at the PX in Guam
she dropped sixty thousand dollars at
the PX on the way
I would think what is at the PX of Guam
that's so great I know it's a big base
but yeah but you get 60 000 worth of
string cheese I wonder beef jerky yes
spam yeah so so you know what's
interesting to me is so you have this
story do the song does the music then
come out of this story does it is that
what suggest or
how does that work how does this
symbiotic relationship between the story
and the music happen creatively wow
um and I demand you to teach it to me so
I can do it since I was now saying okay
this story is going to be set in a disco
uh and
I wanted the audience to be like I would
be in a disco Hearing in the performers
up on little platforms on the side so we
have to have it that kind of energy a
lot of the time telling the story
and
so yeah I went to Fatboy Slim the yeah
musical artist and said you have to help
me do this this is a little bit outside
of my wheelhouse
um we want to really sound like dance
music yeah
and
it it worked and
to me it felt like the kind of buoyant
energy you get from dance music I
thought that must be what it feels like
to be a powerful person like this
to be the
president's wife and you can kind of do
whatever you want
you know I had a friend that saw
um a showing
um previous showing of it and was called
me and was completely blown away just
said this was the greatest the greatest
experience and it was immersive and it
was fantastic and the music was great
and so I'm really looking forward to it
I I'm
um and I don't want to pay for a ticket
that's the other reason I had you on
well they yeah there's people can
arrange we can arrange that no no I I
don't think you understand
I want you to pay me to no uh
oh yeah I went to show up late and I'd
like the the show to stop when I show up
and I'd like a light to hit me okay
because I'm as I as I make my way in
these are things that I demand when I go
places which is why I'm never invited
anywhere
um I'm glad your friend liked it it is a
lot of fun I made it sound like it's a
lot of it's a history lesson but it
the history comes through with all the
dancing and music and everything what
your creative process do you find that
you have
is it the more do you find that you do
the best work say in the morning at
night or is there no Rhyme or Reason to
your your creative engine
um
I found that I've fallen into a routine
where the morning I get up and try and
empty my inbox of emails
never happens
but then by after lunch I can start to
work on whatever
I I really want to work on and it's kind
of like if there's more emails coming in
forget it yeah this is I mean they've
done studies that say that there's
so much creativity
it's really not that much in a given day
someone might have two hours of real
creativity I agree and then after that
everything is busy work and
um I get fascinated by this stuff so
you know Hemingway used to say I'll get
up you get up very early in the morning
and he would
he said if I get right to it I have
about
I think he said two maybe three good
hours
and he said then I know the tank is done
or almost done he said but I always
leave I always stop knowing what the
next thing is going to be to make the
beginning of the next day easier oh I
see which I thought was really like a
kind of a cool trick yeah he didn't he
didn't go to empty he went to there's
still a little bit left and I'm going to
stop here and then the rest of the day
was swimming fishing unfortunately
drinking way too much but he would do
whatever it is that he or boxing you
know uh uh some some Cubist
um painter but but
he then the next day he could say okay I
know where I have about 15 minutes where
I know what I'm doing and that will get
me give me the momentum to get going
again that makes perfect sense I think I
probably do that too and I'd have some
kind of
Administration work in the creative
thing like let's do some edit line
editing let's uh
maybe just try and figure out
some Rhymes and a song that didn't quite
work like go back over it and see if you
can fix it a little bit
but not the heavy lifting of coming up
with something on a blank page